at last year's showcase I told you about
the Elder Scrolls legends a free-to-play
collectible card game now as I said last
year I am a huge fans of these games I
play them a lot so this is a game I'm
particularly excited about legends
provides a very deep strategy experience
through both single and multiplayer
modes beginning with the campaign
complete with a compelling story
interesting characters and some great
gameplay the story is told from the
perspective of a moth priest named
Kellan I'll let him tell you a little
more as we take a look at the campaigns
opening cinematic
the elder scrolls show us what was
and what he had hoobae
and they have revealed much to me spare
us your stories old man unless they can
sharpen Spears our war chief is dying
our enemies are massing for another
attack we must prepare for battle we
should kill him we have this growl we
came for and this one smells blood in
the wind patience knock I have words yet
to speak hear stories can do surprising
things spear maidens
this is the story of a forgotten hero
who changed the very course of history
when Legends begins you're set on a path
to discover the world of the Elder
Scrolls in a way you haven't seen before
the choices you make to find your
approach and unlock all the depth the
game has to offer a two-lane battlefield
provides more variety and strategic
depth players make decisions that change
the cards they want to improve or add to
their decks and we offer full
single-player campaign as well as
multiple ways to play against the AI or
other players in both battle and arena
modes now we began public beta testing
in April and so far the feedback from
the people who have been playing has
been terrific to celebrate III this week
we'll be letting even more of you into
the beta to start playing now if you
haven't signed up yet
just visit bethesda net create an
account and sign up and be sure to keep
an eye on your email also tonight we're
very pleased to announce that in
addition to PC and iPad legends we'll be
coming to iPhone Mac and Android tablets
and phones later this year
as I said I'm very excited about legends
as it brings together an award-winning
franchise that I love and a new genre
and whether you're a veteran strategy
card fan or have never played a game
before it's a game we think you'll all
really enjoy